oh
my god this is
an ear cleaning camera and if you're
anything like me you've seen these
all over your tik tok and your instagram
and whenever i see it
i think it's gross and i cannot look
away but every time i see it i think to
myself i wonder how well that actually
works
so today we're actually gonna put this
to the test
this particular one is the bebird c3
it's from a company called b bird which
makes a number of different ear cleaning
products
this is one of their wireless ones it's
pretty easy to set up
all you need to do is turn it on connect
to the wi-fi network it creates on your
phone and then open up the bird app
where
you will hit start and connect to your
camera there's some wax
ew i actually cleaned out my ears last
week because my eardrum was
totally blocked which is what inspired
me to make this video in the first place
and
let me tell you it was very satisfying
you you oh god
[Music]
i'm so scared to start doing this
i love everything gross i love earwax
extractions
i love pimple popping i know that a lot
of people can't handle it
but i find it very relaxing got this bad
boy all set up
that was actually like a really quick
setup i'm already starting to regret
this
i feel like this is not something i
would have done outside of a
buzzfeed video oh hell no it's kind of
hard to like
orient yourself my ear is very uh
crooked start looking around first of
all why
is the inside of my ear so hairy
oh my god that felt so weird i don't
want to do this anymore
weirdly my ear is a lot cleaner than i
expected
when i saw the tic tac videos people had
like
caked on earwax you can see
some of the i'm assuming that's earwax i
hope so so i hope i don't have anything
else other than earwax in my ear ideally
you wouldn't want it to be like a
cockroach or something right
no
[Music]
oh my
god
[Music]
i'm gonna save this oh look at that
thing
pretty excited that that came out of my
ear you gotta be careful i almost got
too far down there ear wax isn't
necessarily bad like it's really natural
to have earwax it protects your ears
from like
dirt and dust oh i can like scrape some
earwax off the side
you should never need to go like crazy
deep into your ear like that's
not um like a super natural thing to do
oh i guess there's like one weird chunk
over here
i could never be a doctor it's just too
this is too much for me
i'm not gonna lie though it is pretty
satisfying
like you know gratifying to see people
have clean ears oh that was a weird big
chunk oh gross
oh it was actually smaller than i
expected to be
okay oh i lost it where'd it go
it's kind of gross i'm curious if people
actually find it satisfying or if it's
just so grotesque so like you can't look
away you know
i'll be trying to figure out if i have
supersonic hearing now okay
i'm gonna switch to my left ear
for some reason my left ear has always
been like the one that gets the most
satisfaction out of this there you go
you can see like a chunky
a chunky boy right there it's almost
like a video game where you have to
figure out like the right way to orient
your camera oh there's a piece
can i get it i got it
oh she's
juicy i'm scared to go too far
i am scratching a good itch though
oh baby why do i have so much hair in
mine
oh yeah you could see two gross little
spectacles right there
okay i feel like i'm getting a little
more now
that feels so good
so weird to me oh
[Music]
i am relieved i thought that my ears
were going to be super dirty and it was
going to be really embarrassing to show
the whole world
how disgusting my ears are but lo and
behold
looks like my ears have been doing a
good job of keeping themselves nice and
healthy and clean
this ear does feel different i've had
some issues with my right ear feeling
uh like a little blocked up and that's
the one that we got that big chunk along
out of and yeah i just said chunk i'm so
sorry this has been super fascinating i
really enjoy just seeing what the inside
of my ear canal looks like
i think this is a really cool tool i'm
sure every doctor that will just say
like
be super careful with it um i don't like
seeing what's inside of my body
this is way too much information way
more than i need overall
pretty fun don't want to ever do this
again though i'm definitely going to use
this more
i'm also very excited to use this on my
boyfriend but don't tell him that
so for 35 this thing is actually
surprisingly
good i like the fact that it's wireless
so you don't have to have a cord
dangling to your phone
it looks nice it comes in a nice
packaging and overall
this was just like a pretty pleasant
experience to
use aside from you know literally
scooping out your brains
if you're interested in picking one of
these up we're gonna have links down in
the description
[Music]
below
you